in just a few weeks two senate races
special elections in the state of
georgia will decide which party controls
the united states senate
and therefore the united states
government already more than 71
000 people who did not vote in the
general election last month
have requested mail-in ballots for the
january 5th
runoff so how can we be certain
this election is on the level and what's
at stake
donald trump jr thinks a lot is at stake
he's executive vice president of the
trump organization he joins us tonight
don thanks so much
for coming on so to the first thank you
very much tucker i really appreciate it
how can we be certain that this election
is above suspicion in the way it's
conducted
well listen first and foremost i think
we have to pressure our legislatures to
make to make sure that they're actually
watching these things that they don't
allow this sort of craziness that has
gone on
all over the country to go on where
people don't actually have to follow the
rule of law they can adjust the laws
people who aren't actually allowed to
make laws are
implementing new laws that people have
to live by and then saying oh that's too
late we got to figure this out
this kind of stuff is insanity and has
to be pushed back on
we can't allow it to happen we can't
allow ourselves to lose the senate if
you truly believe in conservatism
if you believe in freedom if you believe
in individual rights if you believe in
the second amendment
we have to combat this nonsense we have
to win we have to hold the senate
in georgia and also tucker one thing i
do have to say i appreciate watching the
opening monologue i appreciate you
calling out eric swalwell
as someone who was probably the number
two recipient
of his tinfoil hat brigade attacks about
russia for years
where he called me a traitor i find it
very ironic that he was perhaps sleeping
with a chinese spy that
one but certainly that one had
infiltrated his inner circle and what i
find even scarier is that
you or one of the few people as usual
calling balls and strikes
and calling this sort of stuff out while
the rest of the media
remains silent we shouldn't be surprised
about the media being silent on this
issue
which is truly a national security
threat while this man sits
on the house intelligence committee but
we also shouldn't be surprised that
someone who basically
uh may have soiled himself on national
tv also allowed his agency
and his group to be infiltrated by a
chinese spy so thank you for calling out
uh
swalwell as well i mean the washington
post is owned by jeff
bezos who runs essentially china's
biggest retail operations so maybe
there's a reason they're not saying much
so republicans are very dispirited
they're very distrustful i think they
have a lot of reason to
be both and so some are saying it
doesn't really matter who controls the
senate we're out we're not participating
what would you say to them
i think that's literally what the
democrats
want you to believe they would love for
you
to take this stance that it doesn't
matter
to roll over and die they can pack the
courts
they can attack the second amendment
they'll give d.c
statehood they'll then give puerto rico
statehood you'll have four
permanent democrat senators in a balance
that we will literally
never overcome and it will be a front to
the constitution
and to the freedoms that we hold so dear
tucker this
is what the democrats want for life they
they would love to demoralize you so you
sit at home
allow them to go ballot harvest go win
you know we should be winning georgia
they've changed the game they've
manipulated kovid to be able to do
whatever they want to do
but if you sit back and allow apathy to
take over
and allow that to rule your thought
process you are literally giving the
democrats
everything that they have hoped for and
dreamed for from conservatives for the
last 50 years
we cannot allow that my father's legacy
all of his accomplishments all of the
regulations taking on china
pulling out of endless wars everything
that he's accomplished
is on the table as far as i'm concerned
in this election so if you're a
trump guy if you believe that you'd be
foolish
to listen to a few individuals who say
ah just sit at home
it's as though they're working for the
democrats and giving the democrats and
chuck schumer
everything he's dreamed of for a long
time
it does seem that way to me don junior
nicely put i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you
thank you very much chuck i appreciate
it